[Music]
how do you celebrate when you make a
touchdown you get to celebrate it all
and do like a fun endzone dance at this
age group they don't let you do it or
get a penalty but if I could I would do
something called the Sam down the what
the Sam dance fan okay could you want to
show us right now if they have a
football do you want to try out your if
you were were allowed to do a victory
dance do you want to do one right now
okay let's see it okay so I'm running
and then I just scored
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you mind if I use that at the top of
my show from now on okay thank you I got
a wrench in this Congrats you're on a
wheeze box you got on a Wheaties box
were you excited about this that's
fantastic that's a that's a big
tradition in America to get on a
Wheaties box how did you you know were
you excited about this what had happened
when I first saw this it was on a one of
the TV shows they got a curtain and they
like lifted it up right and I was just
so excited it looks so cool yeah and I
was just so happy okay did you do you
eat Wheaties
what's your favorite cereal
I like Reese's puffs and of course you
do you try how many so how much have you
tried it if you really tried it before
yeah but it's a big honor to be on the
on the on the box that's the important
thing yeah the breakfast of champions
sounded sarcastic
[Applause]
[Laughter]
now I'm just curious you you've had so
much success in football but you have
retired from football because you want
to focus on soccer is that right yeah my
goal when I get older as I want to play
in the national team for soccer and win
an Olympic gold medal and it woke up I
[Applause]
really believe you are such a determined
young person I think that you are going
to accomplish that I really do and I'm
told that you wanted me to do a favor
for you before we were done with the
interview tonight is that right yeah so
my mom and my stepmom couldn't come so
they were wanting you to pull up a sign
that says I love you Brooke and I love
you shirt okay can you just say I love
you Brooke and I love you Jerry did it
do they do they like me yes they're fans
of the show yeah they were so mad they
couldn't come okay then I love you
Brooke I love you Terry
[Applause]
[Music]
who likes me who likes me more Brooke or
sherry I would have to say Brooke okay a
little more time for bra
[Applause]